does the
origin of the meat itself make a
difference
so we're here about campbell farms and
we'll maybe you could talk about
what your vision your dream is on in in
terms of like
food in terms of where food comes from
what meat comes from but food broadly
and how that affects
the entirety of the the culinary journey
on the question of where does it come
from and does that matter
i'd say though the way that meat is
raised is
massively important for flavor and for
how it cooks
um i think most
cooks who try cooking grass-fed versus
corn fed
that's the first moment where they
realize that right where
corn fed meat cooks much more slowly
it's got
bigger veins of fat that slow the heat
transfer throughout the muscle of the
animal compared to grass-fed which is
leaner
heat moves through it more quickly those
steaks will cook much much faster so
there's very kind of technical reasons
why how meat is raised
and that we're aware of and there's
other things that i've noticed
like um that slower growing poultry
has a very very different musculature
and fiber to it
than fast-growing poultry um that's
confinement animals it's just
it has to do with the way that the
muscles are built they tend to be
finer and thinner and more tender um and
a little bit more susceptible to heat so
they the character of the meat's
radically different
it's also much more flavorful when it's
grown more naturally and i think some of
the
the reliance in the us on like
sugary sauces and lots of salts and
flavors and things like that's actually
based on having the broadly available
meat out there is pretty low on flavor
and so we're adding in
a lot to compensate for that so to your
point of like enjoying things very
simply
and and with like salt and nothing else
like
the more flavorful that product is i
think the more people will
find that enjoyable
you